All right, everybody. We're going to go ahead and get started.
I'm Carissa Schreck from Johns Hopkins, and I am excited, along with Dr.
Carrizino, to bring you today a mini symposium, a mini session
on targeted therapy, data-driven approaches, and novel drugs.
And so we have seven very exciting talks for you
today. I'm looking forward to listening and learning from all of them.
But before starting, just wanted to help to frame the conversation,
frame these talks, and put them into context.
Here are my disclosures.
And so I remember being in training a few years ago
and seeing this paper come out. There are several papers
published like this. This one happens to be vemurafenib, where there's a
patient with an incurable, widely metastatic, to
that date, terminal cancer, treated with a targeted agent, in this
case, BRAF V600 inhibitor, whose tumor melts away.
It was near miraculous in that moment, and we really thought we
had turned the corner. And since then, we've seen a bevy,
hundreds actually, of targeted therapies come to the clinical
marketplace. This has been a really exciting 15
years for oncology.
And yet, we've also learned
after that initial response, we get this
bottleneck, right? Tumors respond. They shrink away.
Maybe there's no evaluable disease on PET scan or
MRI, and yet the tumor comes back. The
cancer adapts. Resistance emerges.
This acquired resistance can happen de novo through mutations that are
already present there in clonal heterogeneity. It can be acquired.
It can be through exchanges in expression patterns or new mutations.
We have discovered so many different mechanisms of
resistance, ways that this can change.
And so our paradigm has needed to shift.
It has shifted from this single targetable mutation model towards something
bigger, and I think that's what we're seeing in the talks today, this
systems-focused approach. And so instead of just saying, "What is
the mutation? How do I target it?" We're asking, "What is the larger
dependency?
What combinations can we use to deepen that dependency and take advantage
of it?
Beyond that, how do we develop and deliver these therapies
effectively?
Can we model these mutations, these dependencies, these
networks pre-clinically or alongside our clinical
trials in order to make better choices about which patients should
be receiving novel targeted therapies and which shouldn't or should receive
a different combination?"
And lastly, can we do better by our patients about toxicity?
Can we predict who might get a benefit and should risk the toxicity?
And can we predict what those toxicities might be?
And so as we've gotten smarter, our trials have gotten smarter as well.
And so in addition to viewing this
resistance as it emerges, we're getting smarter about the biopsies that
we do initially before treatment, while on therapy, and
then at progression, so that we have more information about what
systems these cancers are reliant on above and beyond individual point
mutation.
We're also realizing that point mutations aren't enough, right?
It's networks, it's epigenetics, it's proteomics.
And so we are developing better multi-omic
analyses for these tumors, as well as
individualized organoids and humanized models in
order to study
the biology of these systems.
And so I'd like to propose a paradigm, maybe a network way of
thinking about the talks today. I think there are four main
cores, pillars of what we'll be discussing today.
There are so many other points on this web, though, points that each of you are
probably thinking about on a regular basis in your research and clinical care.
But the four we're going to focus on are, first, identifying and
optimizing the right target. Second, intensifying
response through rational combinations.
How do we personalize targeted therapy through model systems?
And lastly, how can we de-risk for our patients through
biomarker?
And so I want to highlight very briefly the seven presentations we have
today so that as you listen, you can be thinking about how they fit into this
framework and how they fit into the ways that you are thinking about research
for your patients and your science.
And so we have two talks today that are really focused on identifying and
optimizing the right target, one that is looking at a multi-epitope
targeting tetravalent antibody platform to develop next generation
ADCs, and another that is taking a highly selective,
long-acting, brain-penetrant PARP inhibitor.
We have two talks that are focused on intensifying response through rational
combinations, and so you'll hear today a story about KRAS inhibition
along with TED inhibition, as well as looking at p53 mutant
cancers by leveraging DNA damage response vulnerabilities.
The third focus, how can we use model systems to personalize therapy,
takes two widely divergent areas, approaches
to answer that same question. So you will have one talk on
using a co-clinical trial model in
patient-derived xenografts, and another that's using a high-throughput drug
screen and really a single-cell approach to identifying
therapies for patients in a very personalized way.
And then lastly, how do we de-risk?
How do I identify the right patient for the right treatment, or who's going to get
toxicity? And so three of our talks focus on that.
One, thinking again about these co-cultured patient-derived xenografts.
Second, the one looking at developing next generation ADCs in a
personalized way. And lastly, a talk that we have looking at a predictive
biomarker for ADC-induced interstitial lung disease.
And so I'm going to stop here and invite Dr.
Juntala to come up from Advaric and discuss his
platform, the MUTA platform for us.
Welcome.
All right. Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you for both the co-chairs for giving this opportunity for us to
speak about this
novel platform that we developed.
And,
all right. With that, I've been in this field for 25 years.
I started my journey with antibody-drug conjugates back in 2002.
I've seen many success stories of approved drugs.
I've been part of that, and I've been also part of that
ADC that went into clinic, didn't make it, and also, I've been part of
ADCs that didn't get into the clinic.
So I've seen all these stories, success, and failures.
And what actually aligns with that is,
if you really look at the success stories, pretty much this copy number,
tumor antigen copy number, and most of this up to the ADC
fall in this bucket. But if you really look at the failed one, almost nearly
150 ADCs didn't make it in the clinic.
They were either paused or discontinued, and they predominantly
solid tumor targets, and they fall in this bucket of 50,000 or
low copies. So again, as you all know, solid tumors,
typically low copy number and heterogeneous expression, and that's been the
challenge. And what we are trying to do here at Arbut is, can we actually
fix these failed ADC targets that went into clinic, didn't make it, and how
can we do it? How can we improve the therapeutic window by
developing multifunctional ADCs?
And that's what we are trying to do.
The window is very narrow, and can we broaden it? How can we do that?
And with that, we developed this
very holistic approach. So in other words, trying to fix
one thing is not going to help. But you got to bring many improvements,
marginal improvements together to improve the
multifunctional ADC approach. And first, with antibody, we
call as a MUTA, which is a multi-epitope targeting tetravalent
antibody. And this is very modular, and it's
plug-and-play. You can work with existing antibody sitting in your refrigerator.
And the beauty of this platform is actually it's a two
plus two design. It's four arms, four binding sites.
Typically, antibody has two binding sites.
And what it does is improves internalization, improves efficacy, and
we combine that with a site-specific conjugation technology which helps us to
improve the safety. And in turn, we developed
recently a platform called AquaLink, which is a hydrophilic link of payload
ADCs. I will spend one slide on that.
And of course, we also bring proprietary payloads and
diversified mechanism action as well as dual payloads.
We are bringing all of them together along with this platform.
And a quick one slide on this AquaLink platform that's
currently being actually presented in the poster session.
Please feel to attend, and we'll happy to take more questions on that.
But the key thing about people who have done hydrophilic ADCs, they
used complicated polymers such as PEG, branched PEG, as
well as
polysaccharides and all that. Our innovation here is
you can work with a simple sugar. What we did is a simple
amino glucuronic acid as a spacer and converted this
entire ADC like antibody-like property.
No increased hydrophobicity at all.
That not only helped us to improve the plasma stability, improved
efficacy, improved bystander activity, and more importantly, did
not affect the safety of the molecule.
Details will be presented at the poster session today, and please feel to
stop by. We can talk more about it.
Coming back to the MUTA platform. So what is MUTA?
As I said, it's four arms. Basically, four binding site you
have. And why are we trying to develop MUTA?
And as you all know, solid tumors, they're heterogeneously expressed.
You have a portion of the tumor as one biomarker, portion of the tumor as the
second biomarker, and they're together.
Can we actually develop an antibody taking care of all these portions?
In other words, open the gates. All gate phenomena,
basically. Our gate and ungate. Every gate, it should work.
And that's where you can actually kill the solid tumor.
That's the basic idea of what we are trying to improvement.
Typical one monospecific ADC just eliminate one portion of the tumor,
but the multispecific ADC, what we are trying to build is take care of all those
portions.
So how did we do that? It was not like a simple story.
It is a four years of our journey on this.
And when you try to develop a new platform, you got to make
sure its manufacturability. In fact, first two years we spent on the
manufacturability of the antibody.
We, again, as I said, our antibody has four arms, tetravalent, and we
went through the literature, looked at, screened all the possible
tetravalent formats. And what was the issue with most of them
is either production
is actually compromised or percent monomer was compromised.
So we had to come up with a new formats. We call that as MUTA 2 and MUTA 4.
Some of them we are going to show today.
And about this new format is production is as good as our
Septintraxizumab, and the yield as well as the percent
monomer as good as Trastuzumab. That was the key criteria we applied
to use this platform.
So,
all right, we developed the platform, and how do you want to apply for
the therapeutics? The key thing is, again, as a company, we are focusing on
solid tumors. And not that we don't want to work with the heme, but
solid tumor is the primary focus and met need was there.
Again, there are about 106 tumor antigens went into clinic using ADC
approach, and about 80 of them solid tumor targets.
So we looked at our own internal algorithms, and to make sure the
available TCGA and gene expression analysis cancer was
normal, we narrowed down to 40 targets.
And that 40, we started pairing them together based on the
co-expression analysisTwo examples were shown here.
MUC16 with NaPi2b and very nicely co-expressed in
ovarian cancer as well as endometrial cancer.
And then second pair, we are showing an example, TRAP2, B7-S3, again,
breast and lung and few other cancer they co-expressed.
And
with that, what we have done is we took these target pairs based
on the expression analysis, paired them.
We engineered MUDA molecules to all these target pairs.
We tested at least 20 target pairs till to date.
The top panel shows MUDA molecules, MUDA ADCs
at either shown improvement over both monospecific ADCs.
The bottom panels, typically, we had MUDA molecules at same activity
as the monospecific ADC or inferior to one of them
or are superior to another one. A typical four examples were depicted on the
right side. Lung AV40 model where we had
blue and brown are the monospecific ADC and pink is the MUDA
molecule. You can see pink is out-beating both the monospecific ADCs.
And lymphoma is one example we wanted to showcase because it's a homogeneous
expression. When you have both target a homogeneous expression, you can see a
very good superiority over both the monospecific ADC, but solid tumors you don't
see like that kind of expression. And then colon and again, head and neck, we
can see again, MUDA outperforming both the monospecific ADC.
I think this is what helped us to think through and
take the programs further. And today what two quick
case studies we are going to showcase. One is the AV003 and AV021.
Two examples we are going to showcase.
And yesterday, in fact, we presented this poster in
collaboration with our partner, Ardent BioPharma.
This is a collaboration program. And again, when we started
is why MUC16, NaPi? I already showed you this,
both biomarkers are very nicely co-expressed in ovarian endometrial
cancer. So we developed this tetravalent
antibody, which binding two N-terminus at the NaPi2b
two binding sites, C-terminus and MUC16 two binding sites.
And then we combined that with the site-specific conjugation with the DAR4
MMAE in this case. Again, MMAE is a well-validated clinical
linker payload. So we combined all these features, and all the data was
presented during yesterday morning session.
And a quick summary of this data showcasing how this
is important by combining this target, what kind of data we got it.
In the next slide, we are shown that.
Again, what you're seeing is improved internalization, improved efficacy.
I want to spend a minute on that, why it's important.
Again, if you know the biology of MUC16, MUC16 is a
very good internalizer. In fact, we quantified that after 20 hours,
MUC16 antibody conjugate actually internalizes very well.
Whereas NaPi is a good expresser, but a poor internalizer, in fact, compared to
MUC16. When we combine these two in a one plus one design, typical
bispecific format, it didn't help much because you're compromising the
valency of the antibody for each target.
Again, didn't improve the internalization.
But when you combine with the two plus one, two plus two design of dual
targeting tetravalent antibody conjugate, you can see a robust
internalization. And when we have taken this further in
vitro potency in vivo, and we can look at this in vivo very
nicely, the MUDA molecule has a robust improvement in the efficacy,
and this was our goal. Improving the minimal efficacious dose
is the goal for us from all along, and MUDA actually beating
both the monospecific ADCs. And in addition, the combination of the ADCs
also it actually improved over the brown line, actually it is.
Simple combination doesn't help.
You got to engineer these binders into the same molecule,
and that's where you show the improvement in the efficacy.
So again, we went on to test this, by PK in the
monkey. We had three different doses and, one mg,
three mg, and nine mg per kg. And what we are showing is a nine mg PK, and you can
see total antibody ADC has a very nice overlapping profile.
Means the molecule is very stable in the plasma.
And we also looked at the safety profile of that.
And again, no findings at one mg or three mg per kg.
But we are seeing reversible reticulocyte decrease at nine mg per kg,
so that's our tolerable MTD, basically.
And when we compare with the typical MMAE ADCs in the monkeys, and
most of you know monkeys do not tolerate more than six mg per kg
when you have DAR4. And at three mg per kg, what we see
safety finding, we are seeing at nine mg per kg.
Again, we improved the safety as well.
So improving efficacy, improving the safety, so that is helping us to
improve the overall therapeutic window of the molecule.
So switching the gear to the next program, I'm not going to spend a lot of
time on that. And this is AV021, B7-H3,
TRAP-2. I already showed you why it's rational.
Co-expression is extremely well.
This molecule we engineered four different orientations, and
we identified only one orientation works really well.
That is TRAP-2 at the N-terminus, B7-H3 at the C-terminus.
And this molecule binds independently TRAP-2 and B7-H3.
And in fact, this molecule showed potency over monospecific
ADC in two different cell lines we tested.
When you have B7-H3 medium TRAP-2 high and reverse, you can
see both cases, MUDA outperforming both the scenarios.
We also showcased in one of the model in vivo, again, outperforming one of
the monospecific ADC. Other one is similar because it's a TRAP-2 high model.
So we are looking at the different models to showcase this is indeed the true, the
MUDA actually outperformed it. So end of the day, I think we have done
a very good progress past four years being a small company.
But as you know, we have already partnered one program.
We have at least another 10 of them are available.
If anyone is interested, we'll be happy to discuss and happy to partner and
take this further. Again, it's not a simple effort.
There is a saying that to raise a
child, you need an entire village. You need a huge team to support this.
Thanks to my Arbut team members and advisory board and
board. More importantly, our collaboration partner, Ardent BioPharma, who
helped a lot to get this done. And also our
early CROs, Enzo Bios, Altion, and Chemview and many
other CROs who helped with this. Thank you for listening and happy to take
questions. I have-200 minutes. Thank you.
We have a couple minutes for questions.
Please use the microphones located in the room.
Hi, it's great to finally see the data coming out of ARVIK.
Do you think there will be less need for selecting patients
based on antigen expression when you have the
multi-target approach?
Yeah, that's a great question. In fact, we looked at the
target expansion in these
ovarian patients, looking at the RNA data at this point,
and it is 90% coverage actually. So,
of course, the ISC data has to reconfirm on that, but RNA data looks already pretty
encouraging, and probably you don't need to screen the patients
at least for this program.
Yeah. Great.
Hi, great data.
Just want to know about the tumor penetration of these
tetravalent, the turbo.
Yeah, no, that's a fantastic question. In fact, we spent two years to fix that.
So when we started, we had a tetravalent molecule, 250
kilodalton. So I know IgG is 150 kilodalton, so we
brought it to 200 kilodalton to cut down the size.
So at least in our hands so far, I know people with 500 kilodalton
also went with IgG fusions, IGMs and all that, but
we do agree size should be important, and we did
bring it down to 200 kilodalton. I think its marginal
increase should be okay. Yeah. Thank you.
A follow-up question to that is, do you think these will be brain penetrant?
This will bring what?
Will these penetrate the CNS, do you think?
Yeah. That's, again, typically,
I know you're going after GBM probably.
For GBM, the blood-brain barrier is already collapsed.
So, and you as a clinician, probably you know this better
than-- People directly inject into the brain, right, for GBM treatment,
not through IV. So,
yeah, it'll be interesting question, but,
it's something we are looking into that, whether adding a blood-brain
barrier,
activity we can actually add in. We have
four binding sites. One of them we can actually add a transferin
receptor, one of those who can support that. So that option is there.
So we can add up to four epitropes. We only exploited two so
far. So there is other
effector functions we can certainly add into that.
Thank you.
Wonderful.
Thank you. Thank you very much for that excellent talk.
Now we'd like to invite Dr. Kerwin to give his presentation.
Thank you very much.
Going along these lines, talking about IDH mutant glioma.
Thank you.
Good afternoon. Thanks for having me.
I'm Patrick Kerwin from the Califano Lab at Columbia University.
Sorry.
Today, I'll present our work using high-throughput drug screening and single-cell
network analysis to identify rational combination therapies in IDH
mutant glioma.
Here are my disclosures.
So adult diffuse gliomas split into IDH wild type and IDH
mutant. What I'll focus on today is IDH mutant glioma,
which separates into two diseases, oligodendroglioma and astrocytoma.
As the survival curves show, oligodendroglioma patients tend to do the best.
Astrocytomas are intermediate, and IDH wild type glioblastoma has
the worst outcomes. But critically, even in the better prognosis
IDH mutant tumors,
these tumors inevitably progress and are uniformly fatal.
Two key factors drive treatment failure.
The first is single cell heterogeneity.
So the IDH mutation driving this disease produces the
onco-metabolite 2-hydroxyglutarate, or 2HG.
2HG drives global hypermethylation, both at the DNA and histone
levels that lock cells into multiple differentiation impaired
states.
The current standard of care, which includes resection, chemoradiation, and more
recently, IDH inhibition, tends to achieve disease stabilization for some
time, but there's eventually progression because this heterogeneity is not
addressed. So in other words, current therapy is successful in
buying time while preserving quality of life, but it's not curative.
So with the disease context in mind, our objective is to identify and
therapeutically target cell state-specific dependencies in IDH mutant glioma
and design rational combinations that go beyond disease
stabilization. And our approach has three parts.
First, we define state dependencies by building an IDH mutant regulatory
network and inferring the master regulators that control each malignant state.
Second, we turn these MR programs into drug predictions using high-throughput
perturbational data in MR-matched cell lines, identifying the
compounds that selectively invert each state's regulatory program.
And finally, we validate single agents and combinations in patient-derived
acute slice explants with single-cell readouts, testing whether the
targeted states in fact contract or shift as predicted.
We generated over 250,000 single-nucleus RNA-seq
profiles from 20 primary treatment-naive resections, 10
oligodendrogliomas, and 10 astrocytomas sourced from the Columbia
Biobank. And importantly, enrichment analysis
using established gene sets confirmed the presence of previously described
MPC-like, OC-like, and AC-like malignant cell states
across both oligodendroglioma and astrocytoma
tumors.So what are master regulators?
So master regulators are transcriptional bottlenecks that funnel diverse
upstream mutations into stable tumor cell states.
To identify them, we use a two-step pipeline.
First, Arachne reverse engineers a gene regulatory network from
expression data, linking each regulator to the genes it controls.
Then Viper infers a regulator's protein activity not from its own
mRNA, but from the coordinated behavior of its targets.
So if a regulator is active, its positively regulated target should be up,
and its negatively regulated target should be down.
The output is a small set of master regulators that establish and maintain each
malignant state. So instead of calling a cell NPC-like because
marker X is high, we ask which MR program is enforcing the
NPC-like state. So a mechanistic state definition rather than a
descriptive one. And because MR sit at the
convergence point
of upstream alterations, they give us an actionable therapeutic handle.
You target the MR program, and you can collapse the cell state.
So now that we've defined cell states in the protein activity space, the next
question is whether their master regulator programs are conserved across patients
and histologies. That's what this heat map is showing.
The columns are single cells grouped by state, AC, NPC,
and OC-like, and the color is Viper activity, with red being high and blue being
low.
And the pattern we see is pretty clear.
AC and OC-like have coherent but
largely orthogonal MR modules, and NPC-like sits
between them, sharing part of the OC-like program.
But the key takeaway is that these state-defining MR programs are conserved
across both oligodendroglioma and astrocytoma.
That's the
blue and
purple you see at the top there.
So these are two genetically distinct diseases that nonetheless converge on the
same regulatory architecture at the cell state level.
This means our therapeutic strategy can generalize across these glioma
subtypes and critically serve across patients.
Zooming in, each tumor state is defined by its own master regulator program.
In the AC-like state, this represents an astrocytic malignant
program defined by Hes4-driven Notch signaling, Sox9-mediated
astrocytic lineage identity, and Id4-sustained plasticity.
In the NPC-like state, we're seeing a progenitor-like malignant state defined by
EGFR-driven growth signaling,
Neuroligin-1-associated neurodevelopmental identity, and
Chd9-linked chromatin plasticity.
This is consistent with a population that's primed for growth, invasion, and
adaptive reprogramming. The OC-like state represents an
oligodendroglial malignant program in which
Gpr17 and Sox10 enforce a canonical progenitor identity,
while Bpm2 reinforces the oligodendroglial
differentiation block. So critically, each of these programs
implies a distinct therapeutic vulnerability.
So with the state-specific MR programs defined, the next question was: Which drugs
are most likely to collapse each cell state?
To answer this, we used PlateSeq, a high-throughput drug perturbation platform.
We treated MR-matched, patient-derived cell lines with a library of
372 FDA-approved and investigational oncology compounds,
then profiled the transcriptomic response to each drug versus vehicle control.
Treatments were at the IC20 for 24 hours, the goal being to capture early
regulatory changes, not end-stage toxicity.
And the result is a perturbational profile for each drug that we can compare
against the MR programs defining each tumor state.
We then use OncoTreat to rank compounds by how strongly they invert
the master regulator module sustaining each state.
In other words, how effectively each drug is predicted to collapse that state's
regulatory program.
To do this, we compared Viper protein activity signatures in drug-treated versus
vehicle control cells and asked how well each perturbation
flips the top activated and repressed MRs defined in
each state. The output is a drug-by-state
matrix scored by the significance of MR conversion.
Here we're reporting as minus log base 10 of FDR,
where higher scores indicate stronger predicted reversal of the malignant
program. So conceptually, this lets us ask two complementary
questions. Which drugs normalize a malignant MR program,
and which may drive state transitions?
For example, pushing a more stem-like NPC population towards a more
differentiated OC-like state.
And that gives us a rational basis for prioritizing state-selective drugs and
combinations.
So although OncoTreat nominates mechanistically diverse drugs, the hits for
each state converge on a small number of core vulnerabilities.
So in the AC-like state, cisplatin and enibritib both target DNA
damage and repair as a key weakness, exploiting the HR repair
vulnerability of IDH-mutant cells.
In the NPC-like state, DS 651b and dabrafenib
both suppress MAP case signaling, the dominant growth dependency in this
stem-like proliferative compartment.
And in the OC state, micofenolate and thioguanine both
hit purine synthesis, pointing to a metabolic
vulnerability specific to this program.
The key point is that across the three malignant states, OncoTreat identified three
distinct vulnerability programs, each actionable
with existing compounds.
So lastly, we move into ex vivo validation.
Here we're using patient-derived acute slice explants.
That's freshly resected tumor tissue that's sectioned and treated within
hours of surgery. So unlike cell lines, these preserve the native
human tissue architecture, cell-cell interactions, spatial niches,
and microenvironmental context that gets erased in standard
models.
So the slices are treated with our candidate single agents as well as combinations,
and we profile cell state changes by single-nucleus
RNA-seq.This lets us ask not just does the tumor respond, but which
compartments respond and how. And the results of the
first compound set are ongoing, and we expect initial readout in the coming months.
So to summarize, this is a mechanism-based approach to prioritizing
combination strategies for IDH mutant glioma.
We start from the master regulators that maintain each malignant cell state, then
identify drugs that disable them.
We select compounds by their ability to invert a state's regulatory program, not
by whether they simply kill cells. And three findings frame our results.
First, single nucleus network analysis revealed conserved state-specific
master regulator programs across IDH mutant glioma subtypes.
Second, OncoTree prioritized state-specific drug
candidates with distinct mechanisms for the AC,
NPC, and OC-like populations. And third, because these states and their
vulnerabilities are conserved across patients and histologies,
validated combinations should generalize broadly rather than being tied to a
single tumor.
So looking ahead, we're using the explant validation to test which predicted drugs
truly deplete or reprogram each target state, and the most promising agents
and combinations will then be validated in vivo in a recently
published genetically engineered mouse model developed by our collaborators.
Together, this gives us a rational path to combination therapy for a
disease where current approaches remain largely non-curative.
I want to thank the Califano lab, especially Andrea Califano, Luca Zinella, and
Mikko Turunen, and our collaborators, Peter Curnow and Peter Sims,
and our funders at NCI and Holobionation. Thank you. Happy to take questions.
Please come to the microphone for any questions.
So very interesting talk, Dr. Hirwen.
In thinking about the cell states that seem to be specifically
sensitive to some of the different compounds, do you think that
those drugs are suppressing individual compartments
or driving the cells to a different state?
So yeah, I kind of gloss over that quickly, but the
answer is that the pipeline allows us to
predict both, right? And so you can, depending on the reference that you're
using for the
drug perturbation data, you can say
can we use this drug to push, for example, a stem-like population to a more
differentiated one if the reference is the more differentiated population?
Or if you're using normal cells, healthy glial cells,
can you push this towards a more normal phenotype?
And so you can predict both, but the
real readout is in the validation, right?
Can we see that
population depleted,
and determining the difference between are we killing those cells or are we
pushing them to a different cell type?
And so the answer is that in the validation, we should see
if that's actually taking place and which one it is.
All right. Well, thank you very much.
Thank you.
All right, so for the next talk, we had a speaker change, and I'm going to invite
Dr. Guo to come up and talk about age-dependent lung
vulnerability, identifying serum hyaluronic acid as a
predictive biomarker of ADC-induced interstitial lung injury.
Thank you, the co-chairs, for selecting us. And my name is Peng Guo.
I'm going to present this work on behalf of our team.
This is my disclosure. And
as we all know,
antibody-drug conjugates is revolutionizing the solid
tumor therapy. And
for the hundreds of the ADCs right now in the preclinical and the
clinical practice, there is one special HER2 targeted ADC called the
trastuzumab deruxtecan. We call it T-DXd for short or
Enhertu. This is a benchmark ADC leading this
revolution due to its superior clinical
efficacy and broad indications. However, T-DXd
is not perfect. Its clinical usage is significantly
limited by its severe side effects, which is the
interstitial lung disease. We call it ILD for short.
So on average, the T-DXd induced ILD rate is
about 15% across all the tumor types, and the fatal
event rate is about 2.2%, highlighting a significant
unmet medical need to diagnose and treat
ADC-induced ILD.
And previously,
our lab has identified the perivascular macrophages.
They are the major cell type directly engulfing the circulating T-DXd
in the lung and later
facilitate the off-target bystander killing effect and
cause the ADC-induced ILD. And based on this
finding, so we proposed we could use
intravenous immunoglobulin IVIG to treat these
AMs as a potential therapeutic approach for treating
the
ADC-induced ILD in the clinic, and we validate this result in the preclinical
models. So last month, we are very happy to see the
clinicians from McMaster University in Canada.
So they reported they use IVIG successfully treat
a breast cancer patient with grade 4 T-DXd-induced ILD.
And our next goal is to develop a noninvasive companion
diagnostic biomarker for predicting the ADC-induced
ILD. And we start our study from the clinical studies.
So in one of our retrospective study, and we
collaborate with the pediatric oncologistWe use TDXD
to treat pediatric and young patients with a very rare cancer
called desmoplastic small round cell tumor, DSRCT.
And surprisingly, we found TDXD does not induce
ILD in these childhood and young patients.
The ILD rate is 0%, compared with 16% in adult
patients. And the similar clinical observation has
also been made by the American
oncologist. So in this PIPEN 1924 trial, which
is led by the John Hopkins Children's Hospital, they
use TDXD to treat the young patients with osteosarcoma,
and they also observed similar findings.
So in the TDXD,
in the younger patients, they do not induce ILD.
And we think these two clinical observations are not a
coincidence.
We hypothesized that the ADC-induced ILD
may be age dependent, and we use it as our cutting point for
our biomechanical studies. So we first establish a
young and adult mouse model to study the TDXD induced ILD.
For the young group, we use two weeks old mice, and for the adult group we
use eight weeks old mice, and we treat them with ADC
for
90 days. And after 90 days,
so we evaluated ILD rate. For young group is 0%, compared with the
40% of the adult group, and this result is
validated by measuring the lung weights and also pathological
stainings and also the cytokine release.
This study just confirmed that the ADC induced ILD is
age dependent in the preclinical model.
And next, we want to
find if this age-dependent
ILD is related to the ADC accumulation in the lung.
And in this bio-distribution study, we found if we increase the age of
the animal from two weeks to 10 weeks, you will see more and more
TDXD accumulated in these animals.
And so we hypothesized that this may be related to the AM
subtypes. And we next perform a single-cell
RNA sequencing,
to analyze the cell population difference between the young and adult
mice. And we found in the young mice, they have significantly less
AMs compared with the adult mice. And not just
the AM cell populations, the young AMs, they are
also immature compared with adult mice.
For example, for the expression of CTSB, this is a key
enzyme which the cell use to cleave the ADC
linker and facilitate bystander killing effect.
So the CTSB expression in the young group is significantly
lower compared with adult group. And there's another example, which is
SPP1. This is the macrophage secreted factor, which could
enhance endothelial barrier permeability and promote the ILD
progression. And we found in the adult group, after ADC
treatment, SPP1 level is significantly upregulated.
However, the immature macrophages in the young group failed to be
polarized into SPP1 positive state under the ADC treatment.
And beyond the macrophages, we also look at the other cell populations
change during the ADC treatment. And we find out in the adult
group, so endothelial cells, after the ADC treatment, their
numbers is significantly decreased.
However, in the young group, we didn't see endothelial cell
change. So that means the young mice has significantly less
lung vascular damage compared with the adult mice.
And it's not just about the endothelial cell numbers.
So the TDXD also will activate the endothelial
cell from a quiescent state to a more active state.
And for example, so after the TDXD damage in
the adult group, the endothelial cell will upregulate a very important enzyme
called HYAL2. This is a key
hyaluronidase. So the endothelial cell use it to
remodel the extracellular matrix, ECMs,
which this enzyme, HYAL2, will
cleave the polymerized lung hyaluronic acid, and
chop into small pieces. So this HA fragment will be released
into the bloodstream, and we can use it as a serum biomarker to
detect the early lung injury
events.
And sorry. In our next study, we measured the serum
HA levels in the preclinical model, and after 90 days, we found only
in the adult group, we see a significant HA level increase
after the ADC treatment. And if we use this HA
as a single biomarker, we can achieve AUC of 80% with a very
good sensitivity and specificity.
We next want to test this serum biomarker in the clinical
setting. And we are very lucky in China, there is a serum
biomarker panel, has already been approved for detecting liver
fibrosis. This panel include four biomarkers, including
HA, also type IV collagen, procollagen 3
N-terminal peptide, and the laminin. They are all ECM gradients.
And, so because this method is clinically available, we
just need to repurpose them for detecting the
ADC-induced ILD. And also, this
detection is very cheap. It costs only $20 in China
to detect all these biomarkers.
So we conduct a pilot clinical trial to study the serum
biomarker panels. And currently, we have collected about 30
patients' data. And so far, for the HA as a
single biomarker, we achieve AUC of
74%. And if we combine HA with other
fibrosis-related biomarkers, we can improve the AUC to
93% with 90% sensitivity and
85% specificity.And in our next slide, I'm going to
show you these serum biomarker panels can be used for companion diagnosis.
So this is a patient, 61 years old, female with
gallbladder cancer. And in the beginning, so when we recruited her,
she's in the control group without any ILD.
You can see her lung CT image is good, and the HA
level is good. However, along the TDX treatment, we
saw a gradual increase in the
serum biomarker levels, especially the HA levels.
After one month, we saw the HA above the normal range.
However, the CT image of the lung still good.
So the doctor continued the TDX treatment.
And after another four months,
we saw a significant upregulated in the serum HA levels,
above 1,000 nanogram per mil in her serum.
This is above the upper detection limit.
We immediately contact the doctor, and doctor gave her
another
CT scan of the lung. And for this time, the doctor start to
see at the lower outer part of the lung, the patients
started to develop this fibrosis.
You can see the honeycomb structures.
But this is a very early stage of the ILD, and the patient has no
symptoms. We just want to show you that
our serum biomarkers, it occurs before the fibrosis
happen in the lung from the CT image.
And I will stop here. So for the take-home message of my
presentation, first, we identify alveolar
macrophages are the center mediator of the ADC
induced ILD, and also age is a
major determinant of lung vulnerability to the ADC-related
ILD. Second, vascular and ECM remodeling are
important downstream events of the ILD development.
And for the biomarker piece, serum hyaluronic acid, especially
when combined with other fibrosis-related markers, shows
promise as a noninvasive companion biomarker for ADC-related
ILD. And for acknowledgments, I would like to thank the patients
and their families and the caregivers and all the clinicians
and scientists that work on this project.
Also, I would like to thank our funding support.
And thank you very much for your attention, and I'm ready to take any questions.
Thank you.
So please step up to the microphone for any questions so we can all hear you.
Great talk. I just had a question if your group has actually looked
at differences in the expression of CTSB and
SPP1 in clinical human samples
that of patients who've had ADC-associated ILD.
You mean if we measure the CTSB and the
SPP1 in the clinical samples?
No, we cannot get the tissues.
I see.
That is very difficult to get the normal lung tissue.
It's almost impossible from patients. Yeah.
I think I had pretty much the same question to ask.
Have you looked at this retrospectively in large clinical trials at all?
Have you been able to do that, to look at those levels?
I'm sorry, what?
Just it's basically, I had the same question.
Have you been able to go and retrospectively look at data sets through
electronic health records to see if you've seen any of these
changes?
We do not have access to the database.
So you don't have that.
So we conduct the pilot clinical trial. Yeah.
In thinking about your preclinical models, have you
hypothesized any protective mechanisms?
Protective mechanism for...
To maybe create a different phenotype in the adults
when it comes to alveolar macrophages or other factors that may
prevent them from having that risk, identify maybe specific risk factors.
I think the most important
finding we find is the, so for the young
mice, their AMs are immature. Their AMs
has very low phagocytosis activity and also low
antigen-presenting activity compared with the adult AMs.
And that will cause them
phagocytose less ADCs
during the
drug circulation.
Yeah.
Penne Merrick-Bernstam, MD Anderson Cancer Center.
Really, I just want to build on the questions that were asked before.
You mentioned that you can't get tissue, which is understandable, but it's actually
quite common when patients have pneumonitis for them to get bronchoalveolar
lavage. I wonder if that could give you some
more insight into the changes. Have you done any analysis on BAL
samples? Do you normally do BAL, do you know?
No. We work with oncologists, and it's very
difficult to convince the patient to do this, to the sample
collection.
Yeah.
Maybe you can work with pulmonologists. They could be your new best friend.
They can help you with that, maybe.
Yeah.
The second thing is you mentioned that IgG is being explored as a
therapeutic. Do you know if the biomarkers that are circulating
get modulated when given?
Uh.
Is that something you're using clinically yourself in your institution?
Do you know if your oncologists are?
You're asking the biomarker for the IVIg treatment?
Mm-hmm. Yeah.
Doctor will use CT image.
Mm-hmm. Okay.
Yeah.
Okay, thanks.
Yeah. Thank you.
All right. Thank you so much.
Thank you.
All right. Thank you very much. Now we'd like to invite Dr.
Kashyap to the
podium, please, to talk about the co-clinical
trial using patient-derived xenografts.
Good afternoon, everyone. My name is Dhruv Chachad, and I'm a postdoctoral
fellow with the Department of Investigational Cancer Therapeutics at MD Anderson
Cancer Center. And it is my pleasure to present to
you our work on investigating the anti-tumor activity of Dato or
datopotamab deruxtecan in a co-clinical trial with patient-derived
xenografts or PDXs.
This project was partially funded by Daiichi Sankyo to the institution.
Okay.
So Dato is an antibody-drug conjugate that targets the
tropo cell surface antigen-2 or Trop-2,
is internalized, and delivers a potent topoisomerase 1 inhibitor
payload, deruxtecan.
Its safety and efficacy were first assessed in the Phase 1 clinical trial,
Tropion-PanTumor01, and preliminary anti-tumor
activity was also reported in different tumor types.
It is currently FDA approved for hormone receptor-positive, HER2-negative breast
cancer and EGFR mutated lung cancer with
previous therapies.
Our lab has previously tested the efficacy of Dato in PDX
models of breast cancer, and shown here is one such model.
And here you can clearly see that Dato treatment results in
regression of tumor volume over a 21-day period and also
significantly increases time to tumor doubling compared to untreated controls.
So through this study, we showed that Dato was highly efficacious,
but also that more studies were needed into its mechanism and rational
combinations.
To that end, we hypothesized that we could
create PDX models from pretreatment biopsies on the
Tropion-PanTumor01 trial and that
responses to Dato in these PDXes would be concordant with that
of the corresponding patients. Further, these PDXes would then serve as
a tool to test whether Dato activity can be further enhanced using rational
combinations.
So just to give a brief idea of our study design,
we collected pretreatment biopsies from patients before they were
administered Dato, and we implanted these in mice.
The patients saw a response to Dato or saw stable disease,
but eventually progressed. And at that point, we collected the post-progression
biopsies and implanted these in mice.
The
biopsies that took successfully or those that were implanted successfully,
we tested those for efficacy of Dato.
And these successfully implanted biopsies also gave us a biopsy take rate.
So overall, we saw a
biopsy take rate of 47%, that is 23 of 49 biopsies
successfully implanted. Of these, 19 were pretreatment
biopsies with a take rate of 48%, and four were
post-progression biopsies with a take rate of 45%.
Our 20 PDX models represented six different
tumor types, and they also showed a wide range of
Trop-2 expression levels.
So we tested the efficacy of Dato in these models using the NCI
PDXNet guidelines. And shown here is an example of a head
and neck squamous cell carcinoma model, where you can clearly see that
Dato
results in regression of tumor volume on day
21 and significantly extends time to tumor doubling compared to untreated controls.
In another model, a bladder carcinoma model,
we actually see an increase in the tumor volume on day 21.
However, Dato treatment was still able to significantly increase time to tumor
doubling compared to untreated controls.
Both these models
were concordant, meaning that the response that we saw in the models was similar to
the response observed in those patients, and I'll talk about this in a little bit.
But both these models also expressed Trop-2, and this was
a good example of
capturing the variability that we observe
of variability in the tumor types and their responses to treatment.
So taking a step back and looking at the big picture, we saw four
models that showed partial response,
defined by a greater than 30% decrease in tumor volume.
So on your left,
you are seeing the mean tumor volumes
here. Sorry, my bad.
So the mean tumor volumes are seen on your left,
with blue indicative of a reduction in tumor volume and red
showing an increase in tumor volume compared to day zero.
This is the data for just a
21-day period. As you can see, the Dato-treated group shows a clear
reduction in tumor volume as compared to the concurrent untreated
controls that show an increase in tumor volume.
You also see in all four models a significant extension of time to
tumor doubling compared to untreated controls.
That is the data shown to your right in the table.
Five models showed stable disease, which is defined by a tumor volume change
between -30% and less than 20%.
In all
these five models as well, we saw
that Dato significantly extended time to tumor doubling compared to untreated
controls. And finally, five models showed progressive disease,
which is defined by a more than 20% change in tumor volume.
Note that two of these models
were negative for Trop-2.
However, in four of these five models, Dato was still able to
significantly extend time to tumor doubling.
Overall, Dato significantly extended time to tumor doubling in 13 of the
14 pretreatment models that we tested.
Next, we wanted to see if these responses that we are seeing in the PDX models,
was that concordant with patient response?
And to that end, we looked at the patient best response and
looked at the PDX objective response over a 21-day period.
And nine of these
patient PDX pairs were concordant.
However, two models
showedA slight reduction in tumor volume, but not exactly
concordant. And to that end, we considered the PDX
best response on day 42, and compared that to patient
response. And then, as you can see, both these models that
showed delayed regression were actually now concordant with the patient best
response. So overall, we saw 11 out of 14 or
78.6% concordance between patient and PDX responses.
So next, we wanted to delve into the mechanism.
And so we designed a PD modeling assay and we performed card
PPA. To that end, we selected nine pre-treatment models
that were also concordant across a wide range of diseases.
And we classified these models as sensitive, shown here in blue, or resistant,
shown in the red. And we wanted to analyze the data in a tumor-agnostic manner.
And in doing so,
we saw that the dato treatment
significantly upregulated the proteins of the DNA damage response pathway
in the sensitive models, but not so in the resistant models.
We also saw a significant increase in cleaved caspases three and seven
in the sensitive models, but not in the resistant models.
So we next wanted to ask, what would be the best, most
rational combinations? And to that end, we performed a synergy screen for
deruxtecan, which is the payload for dato,
across different drugs in four breast cancer cell lines and
found gemcitabine to be highly synergistic with
deruxtecan. We performed another synergy
screen, this time with dato in five pancreatic cancer cell lines and
used
chemotherapeutic agents that are commonly used in the clinic.
And again, gemcitabine was highly synergistic with deruxtecan.
And we followed this up with a colony formation assay using the pancreatic cancer
cell lines. And we saw that the combination therapy of dato and
gemcitabine was highly effective at reducing the
ability of the cells to form colonies, significantly more so
than the monotherapies. Now next, we wanted to test that in PDX
models.
So, we chose a pancreatic adenocarcinoma
model, and this model was derived from a patient
whose best response to dato was progressive disease.
This patient was also administered irinotecan through FOLFIRINOX
and gemcitabine. So the
patient's treatment timeline history is shown
here on the right. We administered this model with
dato on day zero and day 21, and gemcitabine on day one,
day eight, day 22, and day 29. That is a day and a week after dato
treatment. And we can see clearly that the combination
therapy was highly effective at controlling the tumor growth rate,
also showed a reduction in tumor volume on day 21, and significantly extended
time to tumor doubling compared to either monotherapy.
We
kept the same combination and the experimental approach, and we tested this
combination in another model, a bladder carcinoma model that was derived from
a patient
who also showed progressive disease as best response to
dato. This patient was also administered gemcitabine
amongst other treatments previously.
And again, we saw that the combination therapy was highly effective
compared to either monotherapies.
So we can draw several conclusions from this study.
It is feasible to
generate PDX models for clinical studies such as this one.
Dato shows anti-tumor activity in several different tumor types.
More importantly,
the response of the PDX models to dato
is highly concordant with that observed in the patients.
Dato
activated the DNA damage response in sensitive tumors.
And our synergy screens showed that gemcitabine was
the most synergistic partner with dato
in different tumor types. And this combination therapy was
also highly effective in vivo
in tumors that have been previously treated.
So looking forward, we will now adopt a multi-omics approach to determine
biomarkers of sensitivity and resistance to dato.
And finally, it is
important to take these findings to the clinic where patients ultimately see the
advantages of such studies. And with that, I would like to thank
my mentor and the study lead, Dr. Van der Meer Bernstein,
our lab, our pathology collaborators at Translational Molecular
Pathology, the broader ICT department
at
MD Anderson, and lastly but not least, our patients, families, and caregivers at
MD Anderson. With that, I'll take any questions. Thank you.
While people are coming to the microphone, I'll start with a question.
What is the timeframe it takes to do these kinds of analyses?
And do you think this is something that could feasibly be done
in real time to guide patient
treatment choices in clinic?
I think that's a great question. Thank you.
Yes, it can be done real time, but it's also on a case-to-case basis,
depending on how the
biopsy implants, how successfully it is implanted, how it
responds to the kind of treatment that is being given,
and how the patient is responding in the clinic.
And if everything works out, then yes, you can probably do this real time.
A follow-up question. Were there any
patterns that you noticed in the approximately 50% of
xenografts that didn't take?
No. But what exactly do you mean by patterns?
Clinical patterns. Were these patients who progressed rapidly or
certain sites from the biopsies or any sort of-
Right.
Tumor types? Yeah.
I think
so.
That's a great way to look at it, and that is definitely something that we
will consider,
looking at some patterns that we can identify for the
biopsies I did not take. But thank you for that.
I have a question as well. Very interesting presentation.
I know you focused on dato GEM here.
Do you think that the partner for combination will be different in a
tumor-specific way or in sort of an expression or
co-mutation type of pattern that is
disease site agnostic?
Right.
So I think yes,
if we are looking at a disease-specific kind of an
analysis. But here we wanted to focus on a tumor-agnostic manner
where a larger cohort of patients would see the benefit.
So gemcitabine was probably the most widely used
drug. But yes, definitely, we could see
more disease-specific approaches, combination partners.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
All right. So I'm going to invite Dr.
Bakin to come up to the stage from Roswell Cancer Center and to
tell us about his approach for targeting P53 mutant
cancers.
All right.
Okay. Thank you,
organizers to provide opportunity
to present our work at this venue.
This work supposed to be presented by my former graduate
student, Mohammed Al-Ruwayhi, but he couldn't come
for this presentation.
P53
has been cloned in 1979 as an
oncogene.
Now we know that it's tumor suppressor and it's
most mutated gene in human cancers.
Mutations affect transcriptional activity, disrupt transcriptional
activity, and we know that mutant P53
promotes cancer progression and resistance to therapy.
The major issues,
lack of targeted therapy for P53, and the
current existing therapies at use
are not selective and highly toxic.
Our work fills that gap.
Upon DNA damage, P53 is activated, and
through P21, induces stop in DNA
replication and assist DNA damage
repair.
Obviously,
in P53 mutant, these responses
are compromised. So what we
sought to develop approach
that would specifically target that defect.
Mohammed and Justin
found that P53 mutant cancers
express higher levels of base excision repair
and mismatch repair. However, tumor mutational burden
is still high.
So we thought that we will check base excision repair if
there is alterations.
We develop a method, assay,
to detect and evaluate
BER activity in
cells using
ethenyl deoxyuridine. It's a thymidine
analog that incorporates into DNA and
removes through the BER,
and then gap is filled by the signal strand
break repair with the help of PARP.
What we found that if normal
cells with wild type P53 effectively
eliminate
EDU,
however, mutant
retain for a long time EDU.
Wild type cells accumulate in G1,
mutant in G2.
Clinical thymidine analogs induce
temporal DNA damage,
while if you remove P53 or in
P53 mutant, we see accumulation of DNA damage.
However, it's not sufficient to induce cell death.
We thought this is due to ability of single
strand break repair to repair single strand breaks.
Now, if we come with PARP inhibitor, so we will
enhance that, and this is what's happened.
So,
the interaction was synergistic
specifically in P53 mutant and
knockout cells,
and increased sensitivity to
nucleotide analog.
This two-drug strategy, we call it
inducer amplifier strategy, have been
tested in a
pancreatic colon breast cancer models.
And you see the regimen-Controls
effectively tumor growth, improves survival,
increases DNA damage, and
promotes
cell death.
So this strategy is now being tested
in first in human
clinical trial.
So preliminary clinical data suggests
that the treatment is safe
and improves progression-free survival.
The paper is now ready to be sent
to sponsors Taiho and
Pfizer.
Then we decide, okay, we need to know what's happened.
And we use
P53 wild type and P53 knockout and
look the transcriptome. What we find, as expected,
that the treatment increases expression of
P53 targets and arrest cells in G1.
This
response compromised in
P53 knockout. But what is interesting,
so we see increase in DNA double-strand break repair,
and a stop in mitosis,
and there is no blockade of DNA replication.
So we thought, okay, so
tumor cells, mutant,
arrested in G2 but still attempt to repair
and survive.
We thought if we will come with G2 kinase
blockers, so then we will promote
mitotic catastrophe. So when to
apply? So we decide to test
and first, if we treat cells with
the combination and then wash out the drug, what we
see is that wild type cells regain cell cycle.
But mutant retain G2RS for prolonged
time.
And you can appreciate nuclear size is increased,
and the cells don't divide even after three days.
And
normal cells regain proliferative activity,
while P53 mutant not.
So now,
if we add WEE1 inhibitor after the
treatment, we increase the cell death from
30% to nearly 80%.
This is specific with a combination because PARP
inhibitor alone or in combination with
WEE1 have no activity at all.
Synergistic activity was found for P53
mutant cancers, but not in wild type cells.
So based on this, we suggest sequential two-step
strategy. In priming, we induce
G2RS double strand breaks, and then come with the
G2 kinase blockers
to send cells to death penalty.
So this strategy has been tested using
human clinical two-week schedule
for tasks. In the first week, we treat with
Tas102,
and then in the second week with WEE1.
This regiment was able to effectively control
pancreatic PDX growth
and improve survival. No effect on body weight,
and bone marrow was not affected.
So in conclusion,
this work provides
new, effective two-step therapeutic strategy
for P53 mutant cancers.
This strategy is selective,
low toxicity,
improves outcomes, and it's ready for clinical
testing.
Thank you from the team who worked on this, our
collaborators at Roswell Park, at University of Buffalo,
Vanderbilt University, John Hopkins, and the
funding agencies.
Thank you. Any questions?
So I think that's really interesting to identify this two-stage process.
Do you think that... I guess how did you arrive at WEE1 inhibitors in
specific, and do you think they will be the best
at WEE1 inhibitors? And do you think the WEE1 inhibition will be
the best way to prevent that second step?
It's a very good... It's the question about WEE1,
if this is the best target.
Yes, it's a very good question because we went through the whole set
of G2 kinases
and found
ATR and WEE1 will work.
Mm.
WEE1 is
a little bit better,
giving the
ATR activities in other
steps of the cell cycle and DNA replication.
I think it's more targeted to G2,
will be
more appropriate.
CHK1 is too toxic
inhibition-
Mm
... and ATM is not sensitive at all.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Hi. Quick question about the mutant P53
context for PARP inhibitor combination.
I think at this conference I saw Mosaic
Therapeutics actually combining an MDM2 inhibitor with
a PARP inhibitor to go into clinic.
So how do you think that would work in the context of
activating wild-type P53, and whether or not the
same sensitivities would happen there as in the context of mutant
P53?
Okay. So,
can you just one more time repeat the essence?
Yes. So basically, this same combination has been
identified as potentially working in the context of
wild-type P53 if you treat with an MDM2 inhibitor.
Right?
Yeah.
In a clinic, it's a little bit--
So for example,
we have evaluated already
about 30 patients, right?
In practically about 90% of the patients
that have P53 wild type,
we see the response to
these two drug combination. It's one thing.
But second, so there is no induction of P53 targets.
Okay.
It's surprise.
All right?
It is surprising, yes.
So,
if we treat with single agent,
if we treat it with two agents together, we have response
except for one case.
So
I think
to be seen in real world how the tumors
will respond. Testing in cell lines,
cell
line xenografts, it's not sufficient.
Okay.
Even
with PDX in
a preclinical immune compromise models is not
sufficient.
That's fair. Thank you.
Thank you very much.
All right, thank you very much.
Next, we'd like to invite to the stage Dr.
Liu to talk about a novel
PARP-1 inhibitor.
Okay, thank you for introduction.
Good afternoon.
On behalf of my colleagues, I'm so honored
to present our early stage PARP9,
KBD-1111 here.
It is a highly selective non-actin and brain penetrant
PARP inhibitor.
Before stepping into the data, I'd like to make the
disclosures. All the studies presented today
are funded by Compada Biotech.
To start with, I'd like to summarize the
current landscape of PARP inhibitors.
As we all know that first generation PARP inhibitors
target both PARP-1 and PARP-2.
For
the first generation PARP inhibitor have become
standard of care for patients with BRCA mutation.
Besides this, there are three critical unmet needs
remain. The first, hematologic toxicity
driven by PARP-2
inhibition,
leading to dose interruptions and limits
combined strategies with toxicity
anti-cancer therapies. Second,
poor
blood-brain
barrier penetration limits efficacy in brain
metastasis. Third, dosing burdens.
Currently, PARP inhibitors require
once or twice daily regimens, which impacts
long-term patient compliance.
To address these challenges, we design
KBD-1111. Our goal is to
develop a novel, highly selective PARP-1
inhibitor with CNS penetration and an extended
dosing regimen.
Stepping into the data, let's begin with
selectivity profile.
We compare the KBD-1111 with next generation,
highly selective PARP-1 inhibitors,
AZD5305 and
AZD9574 for enzymatic
inhibition. KBD-1111 achieves an IC50
of 0.36 nanomolar,
which is comparable to the competitors.
In terms of PARP-1 trapping, KBD-1111's
IC50 is consistent with
AZD5305 and slightly better
than AZD9574.
Crucially, KBD-1111 shows a very vague
activity in PARP-2 trapping. Its
selectivity for PARP-1 over PARP-2 is
about 9,000-fold surpass the
competitors. What's more, KBD-1111 also has
broad selectivity-For
PIP families such as PIP five and PIP seven.
Taken together, KBD-111 is a potent PIP one
inhibitor with marked selectivity over PIP two
and the whole PIP family.
For the efficacy in vitro,
we evaluated anti-proliferative
activity in two BRCA deficient cell lines.
KBD-111 demonstrate nanomolar level
potency in both BRCA1 and BRCA2 deficient
cancer cell lines. Its inhibitory effect is
comparable to AZD5305
and superior to AZD9574.
For safety profile, we evaluate
hematologic safety in normal CD34
positive hematopoietic stem cells.
KBD-111 shows minimal cytotoxicity
with an IC50 more than 10,000
nanomolar, which
shows significant improvement than first generation
PIP inhibitor tanazoparib.
What's more, its therapeutic index
is consistent with next generation
highly selective PIP one inhibitors.
For PK properties, we examined
PK properties in several species.
For the exposure profile, KBD-111 exhibits
higher exposure compared to next generation
agents, especially in mice and rats.
In terms of half-life
profile, KBD-111 also shows long
half-life with 20 hours in mice.
It suggests that it has potential to
explore lower frequency dosing regimens.
Later, we measured
brain penetration. As we all know that
blood-brain barrier is a main challenge for
anti-cancer treatment. We are pleased to see that
KBD-111 achieves CSF AUC of
38.6 over nanogram per
millimeter, which is comparable to the brain
penetrant compound AZD9574.
Beyond the high exposure, we also find out that
KBD-111 has better efficiency
in crossing the blood-brain barrier
with Kpu of
0.26. All these PK
properties support its potential to treat CNS
malignancies and brain metastasis.
With the good data in vitro and the PK profiles,
we
further investigated anti-tumor efficacy
in vivo.
In DLD1 BRCA2 deficient xenograft
model, KBD-111 achieves
tumor inhibition with one milligram
per kilogram
Q2W dosing. When the
dose rise to 10 milligram per kilogram,
KBD-111 achieves near complete tumor growth
inhibition.
When compared with the same dose of
AZD5305, KBD-111 demonstrates
superior anti-tumor potency. In terms
of safety profile, KBD-111 is
well-tolerated.
What's more, the unbound
plasma concentrations remains above
the IC95
throughout the entire 14-day dosing
interval.
The exposure profile provides a
robust rationale for Q2W dosing.
Next, we also evaluate anti-tumor activity
in intracranial model.
At
lowest dose, 0.3 milligram per kilogram
with QW dosing.
KBD-111 shows a reduction in
fluorescence signal. When the dose rise to
one milligram per kilogram or three milligram per kilogram,
the effect become more pronounced.
And compared with
AZD9574,
KBD-111 shows superior
anti-tumor efficacy.
What's more, KBD-111 is also well-tolerated,
suggesting that it has a potential to treat
brain metastasis.
Finally, we also evaluate the safety profile in
vivo in rat model.
Compared with vehicle, olaparib shows
a significant reticulocyte
reduction. And at the same time,
KBD-111 with QD regimen also shows
slight decrease in reticulocytes.
In contrast, we noticed that
KBD-111 QW regimen groups, there is
no significant change in
reticulocytes. The findings suggest
that the dosing interval may reduce
hematologic toxicity.When compared with
first-generation PARP inhibitors, KBD-111
qd or qw regimen exhibits lower
hematotoxicity risk than olaparib.
In our toxicology studies
with single dose, KBD-111 reaches
MTD with 300 milligram per kilogram in
both SD rat and beagle dogs.
In repeat dose studies, the safety profile is
stable with 100 milligram per kilogram.
Furthermore, KBD-111 also exhibits robust
therapeutic windows with
83.5-fold
in SD rats.
To conclusion,
KBD-111 is a highly potent, long-acting,
and brain penetrant PARP-1 inhibitor with
superior PK properties in different species,
supporting its development as a promising
candidate for q2w dosing. The
compound also demonstrates much less
hematotoxicity than olaparib and is
well-tolerated in 14-day toxicity studies.
Our phase one trial is onboarding.
Beyond KBD-111, our company has a rich PARP9
in oncology, autoimmune diseases, and
anti-aging. One of our oncology PARP9
was licensed out to Novartis in 2024,
which is not shown in this table.
If you are interested with the PARP9s, please feel
free to contact with us by the email in the
bottom. Thank you so much for your time.
Can you tell me, so
compare the trapping activity of your compound versus
AZD5305 and AZD9574.
Have you measured it?
Yeah. We both compared with AZD5305
and AZD9574.
So do you think that it's
got superior trapping and that's what's helping you dose less
than once a day?
Dose once a day or?
Have you looked at PD to see if you're seeing a prolonged PD effect and that's why
you can dose less frequently on a q2w schedule?
You mean PD properties for-
Yeah.
Yeah. We also evaluated the PD
properties with parallels, but it is
not shown in this
presentation. Yeah.
Thank you.
Can you comment on CNS toxicities given that the
drug penetrates the blood-brain barrier more effectively?
Would you anticipate seeing CNS toxicities or even
secondary CNS malignancies with your molecule?
Pardon? You mean treat
brain metastasis?
I'm talking about toxicities, CNS brain
toxicities from more penetration of drug
and also whether there's a higher incidence of
secondary malignancies in the brain.
I know you don't have that data yet, but I was wondering if you could comment on
that.
Actually, we didn't compare the different
about
CNS malignancies and
brain metastasis. We just test the
CSF,
AUC, and CQU. Yeah.
Yes. I was actually referring to the toxicities, like brain
toxicities.
Brain toxicity.
From the drug. Yeah.
Actually,
I'm not very
familiar with preclinical details because I am focused
on clinical development. But I can
communicate with our preclinical scientist and
back to you later. Thank you.
Hi. Great talk. Thank you. I was wondering, when you measured
the AUC for the blood-brain barrier permeability for the
CSF, was it done in tumor-bearing mice or was it done in
healthy mice?
Pardon? Done in?
Mice that already had established brain metastases or was it done in
healthy mice?
In rat.
Oh, rats that were healthy or did they have brain tumors already?
Pardon? In mice already?
So did they have tumors in their brains or-
Yeah
... was it done in healthy mice?
With
intracranial model, in tumor in brain.
So intracranial model, don't you think that might kind of jeopardize a little
bit the blood-brain barrier permeability?
Yeah. We just evaluate in
MDA-MB-436 model-
I see
... in tumor, in brain. Yeah.
All right. Thank you so much.
Thank you.
All right. I think we'll have to save the rest of our questions for afterwards.
We should have a few minutes at the end-
Okay
... to do some more questions.
Thank you for the great talk. As you
answered the previous question, you are focused on
the
clinical development strategy. So I am wondering what
your
future clinical development strategy will be since your
KDB-111 have a few strong
advantages. Thank you.
Thank you for your question. And for our Phase I
trial, we will focus on safety and
PK/PD profiles. But later for the
subsequent development, we will explore
monotherapy in HRD-positive patients
and combination with other chemo
or ADC to reach more patients in need.
Thank you. Okay, thank you.
All right. Thank you very much.
Thank you.
All right, everyone. I want you to mentally do a seventh-inning stretch right now.
You've been sitting in those chairs for a while, and I know our brains are starting
to get saturated, but make a little bit more room. Can I invite Dr.
Sanchez to come and speak about her data on TED/KRAS?
All right.
Let's see. Is this working? Yep. All right. Hello, everyone.
Thanks for sticking around until the end of the session.
I'm happy today to share our work comparing two different modalities of TED
inhibitors as combination agents with KRAS inhibitors.
So the TED proteins are the transcriptional effectors of the Hippo pathway,
and they become activated following the binding of coactivator proteins called Yap
or Taz. And together, they regulate the expression of a number of
genes broadly important in cancer cell survival, and
importantly for the context of today, drug resistance.
So normally, upstream signaling feeds into the activity of LATs
kinases, which control the phosphorylation status of Yap and
Taz, and thereby its subcellular localization.
But in addition to this canonical pathway regulation, it's
also been appreciated that TED proteins can be
posttranslationally modified in such a way that affects their function.
And that's by a posttranslational modification called palmitoylation,
which occurs on all four of the TED proteins in a region called the
central pocket. And it's been shown that the palmitoylation event is
important to promote Yap/Taz binding and transcriptional
output.
So with this discovery, a number of companies have been developing small
molecules, which are called central pocket palmitoylation inhibitors or
CPIs,
which bind the central pocket, inhibit palmitoylation,
thereby affect Yap and Taz binding and transcriptional activity.
And an alternative modality to inhibit this
pathway involves the development of small molecule protein-protein
interaction inhibitors, which also bind to TED but in a region
outside of the central pocket and can also displace Yap/Taz binding
and turn off transcriptional activity.
So in the talk today, I'll be comparing the activity of the
compound AZD0751, which is a palmitoylation
inhibitor, a CPI,
to the Novartis clinical candidate, IAG 933, which
is a Yap/TED PPI.
So it's been shown broadly in the literature that TED pathway activation
occurs as an adaptive resistance mechanism to a number of targeted
therapies, including EGFR inhibitors and KRAS
inhibitors.
So the data on the left show that cell lines that are relatively insensitive
to KRAS G12C monotherapy tend to have higher
degrees of Yap/TED transcriptional output.
And functionally, it's been shown by our internal data as well
as the publications that a number of Hippo pathway
components come out as either sensitizing or
resistance hits
to KRAS inhibitors.
So we've previously identified conditions under
which TED central pocket inhibitors can combine with
EGFR inhibitors such as osimertinib to delay
resistance in non-small cell lung cancer.
And the question for this study today is whether TED inhibitors can combine
with KRAS inhibitors to provide long-term
combination efficacy and whether these two different modalities of TED
inhibitors affect response.
And again, we'll be comparing the activity of AZ0751, which is a
palmitoylation inhibitor. That data will be shown in blue.
And IAG 933 is the Yap/TED PPI.
And I've included this data on the right just to show you that we believe that
both the CPI and PPI modalities both can
provide comparable activity as monotherapy agents,
for example, in Hippo-mutated mesothelioma.
So we performed a series of long-term incu-cyte outgrowth
experiments where we treated with the TED inhibitors
and here sotorasib as our G12C inhibitor as either
monotherapy or combination.
So to orient you, the data on the left corresponds to the
CPI palmitoylation inhibitor, and the data on the right, the
Yap/TED PPI.
So we found that when we chronically dosed this
NCI-H222 model, which is a G12C mutant
non-small cell lung cancer, the cells became resistant after a
period of around two weeks of dosing.
And the combination of sotorasib with 0751 was able
to partially delay that effect. However, I think you can
appreciate that the combination of the Yap/TED PPI with
sotorasib gave a much more durable and pronounced and
extended response.
And what was interesting is that this was true even in models that were
refractory to G12C monotherapy, but which were
G12C mutant. So, for example, in the
SW1573 model, where we saw that the
combination of the Yap/TED PPI with sotorasib provided durable
benefit.
So both of these are examples of cell lines that are treatment
naive, and we also wanted to know whether this combination could
resensitize cells that had already become resistant to the KRAS
inhibitor.So in these cell Titer-Glo experiments,
we took the
same cell line from the last slide, the H2122 model, which
we had grown to be resistant to a G12C inhibitor called
AZD4625, and treated with either the monotherapy
or the combinations. And as you can see, the combination of
sotorasib with the YAP-T PPI was able to resensitize
the cells that had already become resistant.
And we believe that this is all on-target activity because when you run these
combinations in a KRAS wild-type line, there's no response.
So next, we were interested in expanding beyond KRASG12C
mutant non-small cell lung models to other models, including
KRASG12D colorectal and pancreatic cancers.
So in the GP2D cell line, we grew these cells to be resistant
to Mirati 1133, which is a KRASG12D inhibitor.
And you can see that the combination of the TEAD
CPI with the KRASG12D inhibitor provided
partial delay in that resistance.
However, again, the combination with the YAP-T PPI with
the Mirati inhibitor was able to provide a durable effect.
And consistently, even in models that are relatively resistant to
the Mirati monotherapy, we see that this combination is able to
sensitize the cells in a long-term assay.
And again, in KRAS wild-type control models, we
don't see any evidence of that durable combination
benefit.
So we were next interested to understand the mechanism by which the two different
TEAD inhibitor modalities were providing such differential effects in
vitro. So we performed some qPCR experiments
here looking at different TEAD-dependent target genes,
or here just particularly CTGF, but this is true for other TEAD-dependent target
genes as well. So we find consistent with the literature that if
you treat with KRAS inhibitors, either sotorasib
or the Mirati 1133 for a period of 24 hours, you get an
acute induction of TEAD-dependent genes.
And what I would say is, in general, we see that the PPI
modality is able to suppress TEAD target genes to a
greater extent than what can be achieved by the palmitoylation
inhibitor modality.
And I think the data on the right is a nice illustration of this.
So
we performed cut and run experiments looking at YAP
genomic occupancy at TEAD-dependent loci.
And sorry, lost the pointer. Okay.
And then you can see that the PPI is able to
evict YAP from chromatin to a greater extent than
what can be achieved by the palmitoylation inhibitors.
So we also looked at the effect of these monotherapy and
combinations on MAP kinase AKT phosphorylation
targets.
And what we saw was that, in general, we believe that the activity in
suppressing these pathways in these phosphorylation targets is
largely driven by either the
KRASG12C or the KRASG12D inhibitor
monotherapy, and not further enhanced by the addition
of
the TEAD inhibitors by either modality, either CPI or
PPI.
And we also saw that this was true
at the transcriptional level when we compared the
activity of these combinations on the
transcription of some KRAS pathway markers such as DUSP6 and
FOSL1.
So then lastly, we were interested in translating all of these findings
from the in vitro to the in vivo context.
So we ran three subcutaneous xenograft experiments.
One in the KRASG12C mutant H2122 non-small cell
lung model, and then the two on the right are pancreatic
G12D mutant cancers.
And interestingly, we found that when we did the experiment in vivo,
we actually were able to see that both TEAD inhibitor modalities were able
to combine with sotorasib to provide regression of tumors
while the mice were being dosed, compared to sotorasib monotherapy,
which drove a stasis effect.
And when we stopped dosing and then monitored for tumor regrowth,
we found that both tumors regrew at similar kinetics.
And unfortunately, when we performed the experiments in two of these cell
line-derived KRASG12D mutant
pancreatic models, we were not able to find
evidence for robust combination benefit or tumor
regression. And at least some of these models were responding quite
robustly in the in vitro context.
So to summarize what I've told you today, we've compared the activity of two
different TEAD inhibitor modalities, a palmitoylation inhibitor and a
YAP-T PPI. And I believe that the data support that
the YAP-T PPI provides very strong combination activity,
at least in an in vitro context, and a very durable effect in
long-term assays.
But interestingly, I would say that
despite these differences in activity in the in vitro setting, both
inhibitors were able to provide and drive similar
therapeutic benefit in vivo. And just
collectively, we believe that TEAD
inhibitors may combine with KRAS inhibitors to provide a novel
combination strategy,
particularly in KRAS mutant non-small cell lung cancer.
So with that, I would just like to thank everyone who contributed and
supported these studies,
and I'd be happy to take any questions. Thank you.
Very nice work. So, do you have any comparative study with the
Vivace series of the CPI inhibitors?
Do you have any comment, like do you see similar kind of effects as
the AstraZeneca CPI?
So we haven't compared to the clinical compound of the
Vivace inhibitors. But in earlier series from Vivace, we had
found that our TEAD inhibitors were very comparable,
at least particularly in Hippo mutated mesothelioma.
So we believe that the AstraZeneca inhibitor that I presented
today
is equally as effective as some of those earlier-stage Vivace
compounds. But we have not tested yet the
clinical compound itself.
But just going back to the question of mechanistically how they are different,
do you think it is the retention or
the
amount of time the compound is active in vivo?
Is that what creates the difference?
Yeah. So
what we found from PK/PD studies was that, for example,
so the Vivace compound is a palmitoylation inhibitor.
But if you're thinking about the PPI versus the CPI,
we found that the Novartis compound within a 24-hour period,
looking at the PD from in vivo samples, there was actually a
rebounding of TEAD transcriptional activity that occurred within
24 hours that we don't see with the palmitoylation inhibitors.
So I guess my guess is that that's almost providing an
underestimate of the degree to
which you could actually drive that sustained tumor regression in
vivo. And I'm not sure to what extent that
rebounding of the PD is a class effect or
that's just
something inherent to IAG933. But we did notice that
difference in comparing the PPI versus the CPI
modality.
Really nice presentation, and I think it's really interesting to see sort of the
difference between the in vitro and the in vivo and how this plays out.
The resistance mechanism of KRAS, resistance with KRAS, and where now
it's sort of discussed whether Hippo pathways could be sort of an escape route
for them.
Have you come across any clinical evidence for that?
Because I've seen a lot of people having sort of resistance L models that have
shown sort of an escape via the Hippo pathway,
and it might be my ignorance that I haven't come across the data.
But is there anything from a clinical side that this has been seen
as a mechanism that could be targeted?
Yeah. I think there was a talk yesterday by Andrew Aguirre,
sorry if I'm mispronouncing that-
Yeah
... who
had
samples following KRAS inhibitor treatment or
on treatment.
Mm-hmm.
And I was interested to know whether or not the Hippo signatures are coming out in
the patient samples because I think this has been very well-defined
from mouse models and-
Yeah
... kind of in the preclinical space.
But the extent to which all of those signals are manifesting in the patient
data, I think that's something that we still need to validate.
Okay. Good. Thank you.
A question.
I thought that the difference between the in vitro and in vivo was
really fascinating, and you talked a little bit about maybe this
sort of rebound effect.
Mm-hmm.
Do you think that that is the primary explanation, or are there
potential other explanations for the difference between the in vitro and in
vivo findings?
Yeah. I don't know entirely. I think another thing that we were thinking about
doing was trying to do some of these experiments in vitro in, like,
a 3D spheroid-type format-
Mm-hmm
... that might represent what you would see in vivo
more faithfully. Unfortunately, I was running into technical issues with
that in terms of media changes and such for, like, a month-long
experiment.
But yeah, I would be very curious to see in, like, an organoid or a 3D
spheroid format, whether
you would see more of that benefit with the palmitoylation inhibitor in the in
vitro setting and then whether that would translate more to the in vivo
context. But I don't know in terms of the
specific mechanism that
delineates that. Yeah.
Very interesting.
Thank you very much.
Oh, yeah. So don't walk out just yet.
We have one more session, and that's a discussion section.
All right.
You have made it to the end of the day. Congratulations.
Or the end of this session at least.
Thank you very much for sticking with us, and thank you especially to our
wonderful speakers for the fascinating science that they have presented.
My name is Jenna Canzaniero. I'm a breast medical oncologist at Johns Hopkins
and a translational scientist, and I'm going to be kind of trying to put everything
that we've heard today into context.
These are my disclosures.
So we often talk about targeted therapy as if the central
challenge is target identification.
But for the field today, we have really realized that that's only the beginning.
It's not just a one target, one drug model
anymore. The harder problem now is how to turn a biologic
insight into a therapeutic strategy that is potent,
selective, deliverable, and clinically predictable.
And that requires much more than just a single drug and a single
target. It requires an integrated development
framework, one that can define tumor
vulnerabilityIdentify rational combinations and
engineer delivery platforms, and then test these
combinations in clinically faithful models and anticipate toxicity
before translation. And so, as Dr.
Schreck so nicely outlined before, we've really moved to
this new model here where we have these different pillars all
supporting targeted therapy strategies in oncology, where we're
talking about optimizing the right target,
intensifying response through combinations,
personalizing this through model systems, and then de-risking through
anticipating toxicity.
And so I think each of our speakers today hit on one of these
pillars, and I'd like to just put that all into context.
Here's how we categorize them. So going through them
by pillar as opposed to the order in which we discuss them.
I first want to start with a discussion of antibody-drug conjugates.
So as was mentioned, there's really been an explosion of ADCs in the clinic in the
past year with eight ADCs now approved across multiple
tumor types, including breast, GYN, gastric, bladder, and non-small cell
lung cancer.
However, one of the challenges limiting ADC development is the need to
identify a surface antigen that's expressed in a large enough
quantity on the tumor cells and differentially expressed compared to
normal cells.
And so,
while there has been these successes in certain cancer types, it's
important to note that all the current clinically available
ADCs are only targeting one single cell surface antigen,
and that several of these ADCs are actually targeting the same antigen.
So we have two ADCs against HER2 and two ADCs
against Trop-2.
And in this session, we heard from Dr.
Junitula about a novel approach that they are taking to try to develop
ADCs that move away from targeting a single
cell surface antigen to targeting multiple
cell surface antigens. This has the potential to increase the number
of cell surface targets that could be used, allowing for the expansion
of ADCs into other cancer types
that potentially don't have a single identifiable target,
and potentially addressing other issues related to heterogeneity
of the target expression across different metastases, as well
as downregulation of target expression that can limit efficacy.
And indeed, they showed some very promising data in support of this approach using
a dual target MUC16 and NaPi2b
tetravalent antibody drug conjugate, which outperformed the ADCs
against individual targets in a model system.
So very excited to see the direction that this work is going.
Moving now to PARP inhibitors. So PARP inhibitors have been
recognized for several years as generating synthetic lethality
with homologous recombination deficient tumors.
So there's currently four approved PARP inhibitors, olaparib,
talazoparib, niraparib, and rucaparib, across four different
malignancy types, so ovarian, breast, prostate, and pancreatic cancer.
However, there are significant challenges with the currently approved PARP
inhibitors, including limited brain penetration and significant
hematologic toxicities
with the current
PARP inhibitors having
ranges of all-grade anemia from 37% to 50%,
thrombocytopenia from 14% to 61%, and
neutropenia from 18% to 20%. And as a clinician who uses
these drugs in the clinic, I can tell you that this is a significant issue that we
deal with, and it is oftentimes the cause for either
discontinuing the drug or having to dose reduce.
So as was shown today by Dr. Liu with the development of this
novel agent, KBD-111, they have developed a PARP1
selective inhibitor that demonstrates both intracranial
activity as well as limited hematologic toxicity in in
vivo animal models. And so this optimization will hopefully
enable broader utility for PARP1 across HRD
cancers. And so this, I think there's a broader push.
There's multiple compounds, PARP1 specific compounds that are coming to market.
But I think this will be an interesting compound to follow.
Moving now to the next pillar, which is rational combinations,
and starting with KRAS and TIDE. So as I think
we're all very familiar, KRAS is one of the most commonly altered
genes in human cancer.
It's very commonly mutated, particularly in pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma, colorectal cancer, and non-small cell lung cancer.
And the majority of these mutations are at the hotspots of G12 and
G13. And there's truly been an explosion in the
past, let's say
five years,
of KRAS inhibitors, with over 70 RAS inhibitors
currently in development and approximately 150 trials that are
currently actively recruiting for RAS inhibitors.
So there have been numerous sessions at
AACR talking about RAS inhibitors and presenting some of this
RAS inhibitor data. So this is definitely an area that is very
exciting.
However, despite all of this excitement about KRAS inhibitors, none of these
are curative, and so eventually these tumors do develop
resistance, and patients will have progression.
So one of the
mechanisms, and I guess it remains to be a question of whether this is really going
to play out in clinic, but certainly a pre-clinical mechanism that has been
identified
for resistance to KRAS inhibitors is mediated through the Hippo
pathway, in which YAP/TAZ binds to TIDE, driving
transcription.
And TIDE inhibitors have been proposed as a combination therapy with KRAS
inhibitors to prevent this mechanism of resistance.But just
as there are multiple different types of RAS inhibitors,
mutation-specific, pan-RAS inhibitors, all of these different kinds of RAS
inhibitors,
there are also different ways of inhibiting TEAD.
So there's a central pocket
interface inhibitor which blocks TEAD palmitoylation, and
there's a protein inhibitor which directly blocks the interaction
with YAP/TAZ.
So here, Dr. Sanchez very nicely asked how these
different approaches to TEAD inhibition might impact the
efficacy when combining them with KRAS inhibitors.
And I thought this data was particularly interesting because while they did find
very notable differences in the in vitro cell lines with the
protein inhibitors being much more effective, this difference
really did not translate into the non-small cell lung cancer xenograft
models. And I think that's part of why I asked that question.
It remains to be seen exactly why this is,
but interesting. And additionally, and a little bit disappointingly,
there really didn't seem to be any additive benefit to either TEAD inhibitor when
you were looking at the pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma G12D model.
So
I think this suggests that the mechanisms of resistance to
KRAS inhibitors are complicated and probably more work needs to be
done to really understand how these are working.
And it will be very interesting to see how the ongoing clinical trials that are
incorporating TEAD inhibitors with KRAS inhibitors turn out.
Moving now to TP53.
So even more than KRAS, TP53 is the
most commonly mutated gene in cancer, with
an estimated 50% of all cancers having a TP53
mutation.
So with this very high prevalence, it would seem that TP53 would be the
perfect target. You can get all these different cancer
types.
But what we've seen over the past 30 years is that TP53
is actually very hard to target,
with numerous failed attempts.
There's been adenoviral P53 gene therapy, MDM2
inhibitors, non-selective mutant P53 inhibitors, P53 vaccines.
The list actually could go on and on.
There were several very high-profile phase three trials that failed.
So P53 has proven to be a very
difficult target,
and I think there's a lot of different reasons for this.
So I think these repeated failures reflect some fundamental challenges with
targeting P53. First is that TP53 is a nuclear
transcription factor. It doesn't have a traditional druggable binding pocket,
so it's a little bit harder to go after.
Additionally, mutations in TP53 occur across the entire genome
with over 2,000 distinct variants identified in cancer.
So making it much harder to design compounds that are mutant selective
because you have so many that you need to think about.
Additionally, TP53 mutations are loss-of-function mutations, and these are
often accompanied by biallelic inactivation, and so mechanisms that are
going to restore the activity of one allele are probably insufficient.
And finally, TP53 mutant cancers tend to harbor many co-occurring
alterations that provide alternative survival pathways, and so
many mechanisms around whatever inhibitor you may be trying to throw at
this.
However, despite these challenges, people continue to try to
target TP53. People still want to go after it, and
there is some glimmer of hope.
I will note there was, just two months ago in "New England Journal of Medicine," a
positive phase one study of this TP53
mutant-selective Y-220C inhibitor.
So there's been previous positive phase one studies that didn't end
up turning out, but this is the latest one, so fingers
crossed. Hopefully, this one will be different.
Here, we saw wonderful and exciting data from Dr.
Bacon, who have attempted to tackle this challenge of
targeting TP53 using a synthetic lethality approach.
The combination of the thymidine analog TAS-102 and PARP
inhibitors has previously been proposed as a synthetic lethal approach for
TP53, and this combination is currently in an ongoing clinical
trial.
Interestingly, when they were examining this combination in model systems, they
found that this two-drug approach leads to G2 arrest in the
TP53 mutant cells, which could potentially be a mechanism of resistance by
impairing cell death. And so they, further
investigating this, they identified that this was mediated through the ATR pathway,
and by applying a WEE1 inhibitor, were able to release the cells from G2,
leading to mitotic death. So based on this, I think they proposed a
very elegant solution with a triplet approach
using serial dosing of TAS-102 and PARP inhibitor and WEE1
inhibitor to try to manage the toxicity.
Very thoughtful,
rational combination. And I think this work really highlights the
complexity of using synthetic lethality to target TP53 with
the many possible escapement mechanisms.
And I want to congratulate this team for continuing to try to tackle
this very
difficult problem.
Moving now to the presentation by Dr.
Kerwin,
and focusing here, transitioning to model systems, but
also rational combinations. I think this
presentation hit two of the pillars.
Here we saw that they utilized a model system to identify rational
combinations of drugs to target IDH mutant glioma, which is a
devastating and uniformly fatal disease.
They used single-cell RNA-seq from 20 patient samples to
identify three master regulator classes of IDH
glioma, and then they matched these classes to patient-derived cell line
models.Which they were then able to use to perform a drug screen
using OncoTreat to identify cell state-specific drug
candidates, enabling rational combination
strategies. So I thought this was a really elegant model
for trying to come up with these rational combinations, and I look forward to
seeing the validation in the
slices from the brain.
Whenever we talk about personalizing targeted therapy, we run into these
contrasting thoughts about approaches.
One of which involves understanding the genomic mechanism of growth and resistance
and using that to identify targets, and the other is moving to a more
functional-based approach, and involves establishing patient-derived tumor
models and evaluating ex vivo drug responses.
And this functional-based approach was the one that was
taken by Dr. Chachad and colleagues.
Here, they did the biopsies from the Phase 1 Tropion-Pan
tumor basket trial and implanted these into mice,
and were able to test the efficacy of ado-trastuzumab deruxtecan, so a
Trop2 antibody-drug conjugate. Here, they found a very high degree
of concordance in response rates between the PDXs and the patients.
And furthermore, the concordant PDX models
enabled the evaluation of drug combinations, and in this case,
identified dato-DXd and gemcitabine as a
potentially synergistic combination.
So here we see another excellent example of using a model
system to predict patient-specific responses, as well as
further enabling the evaluation of rational drug combinations.
So again, hitting two of these pillars.
Very nicely done.
And then finally, for our last abstract and our last pillar,
which was presented by Dr. Guo,
looked at predictors of toxicity in treatment from antibody drug conjugates,
specifically pneumonitis related to treatment with trastuzumab
deruxtecan. So pneumonitis is a rare but serious
side effect of trastuzumab deruxtecan that has been recorded
across the studies for T-DXd in different cancer types.
And importantly, this includes some Grade 5 toxicity, which
for those of you not familiar with that, that is death.
And this is really important when we think about moving T-DXd earlier and
earlier, and particularly in breast, we're moving it earlier and earlier
into adjuvant, neoadjuvant space.
We do not want death to be a potential side effect when we're trying to cure a
patient.
So here they did some elegant studies using aged mouse models,
and they found that endothelial cells have high levels of induction of
HYAL2 and TMEM2 activation, which leads to hyaluronic
acid release into the circulation.
And they were able to correlate levels of hyaluronic acid in the
circulation with the development of interstitial lung disease in a patient
cohort, which indicates the promising potential of this as a
diagnostic biomarker. And I think this is very exciting work.
I think still additional validation is needed, but any
advancement towards
improving our ability to predict or have early detection
of this potentially devastating toxicity is really welcome.
And so with that, I will conclude and just bring this all together
to say that targeted therapeutics are really entering an exciting new era
using data-driven approaches, and that the new model of developing
these targeted therapeutics is relying on these four pillars.
It's becoming increasingly more complex, but will hopefully lead to better
outcomes.
I just want to thank everyone who's presented in this session today.
Amazing work that all of the researchers and clinicians are doing here.
And especially thank you to the caregivers, advocates, and funding agencies who
support this research. But most importantly, thank you to the
patients who have donated their samples.
I think it's really important, particularly for those of you who don't see patients
in clinic, to remember that these are the people that we're doing all of this
for, and it really makes a huge difference to them.
So thank you all very much.